the reason money should be truly  decentralized is because if anybody has  the power they will abuse it sooner or  later and we've seen this over  millennials so that one piece of power  that nobody should possess and everybody  can agree that nobody should possess is  the global value just like us currently  has more or less the power of  manipulating global value because most  people use a dollar standard  so they're abusing it right they're  paying a lot of money to maintain  trading routes that suspend the dollar  value so they can print the dollar and  essentially ensuring like slowly taxing  everybody who's using the dollar so  stealing everybody kind of agrees that  that's the one thing  nobody should have right nobody should  be that powerful and everything else is  not so important we can use in a  database